Le golfe persique arabique
est situé au centre
du Moyen-Orient.
Sur la côte sud
est l'état du Qatar,
qui occupe une péninsule
d'un peu moins de 11 500 kilomètres carrés,
une zone près de 200 fois
plus petit que l'Arabie Saoudite.
Jusqu'au XXe siècle,
les principales ressources de la péninsule
venait de la mer.
A son point le plus large, le pays
ne mesure que 80 kilomètres de diamètre.
Une multitude d'îles
entourent ce territoire,
qui pour la plupart
une partie est un vaste désert plat
dont le climat et le sol aride
sont inhospitaliers à la végétation naturelle.
En hiver, les fortes pluies sont fréquentes,
et pourtant la couleur revient au désert.
La gestion rigoureuse de l'eau
et des systèmes de distribution méthodiques
permettre le désert
fleurir au plus fort de l'été.
En sortant de sa coquille,
Qatar depuis de nombreuses années
concentré sur l'huître perlière.
La Perle lancée
l'économie de ce pays,
et la famille al-Thani
a donné au pays
sa constitution et sa renommée.
Situé sur la côte Est,
Doha, la capitale, a été complètement
transformée au cours des 50 dernières années.
Quatre-vingt pourcent
de la population du pays vit à Doha.
La croissance ultra rapide de cet émirat,
qui a proclamé son indépendance en 1971,
n'entre pas en conflit
avec son respect de la tradition.
L'état du Qatar
a choisi la santé, le bien-être et l'éducation
comme ses principales priorités nationales.
La même importance est accordée
à l'éducation physique et sportive.
Les grands objectifs du pays dans ce domaine
sont reflétés par le nombre
d'événements sportifs internationaux
qui sont hébergés ici.
L'apprentissage est une autre priorité.
Toute la société qatarienne
doit y avoir accès.
Les femmes trouvent les moyens de leur émancipation
en acquérant des connaissances
et maîtriser le savoir-faire technique moderne.
La qualité de l'enseignement
et des échanges constants
avec d'autres pays
également veiller à ce que les valeurs du Qatar
sont partagés avec le reste du monde.
Ici, la révolution numérique
va de pair avec les coutumes ancestrales.
Seulement un tiers
de la population est d'origine qatarienne.
Les autres sont des expatriés étrangers
qui constituent une richesse de savoir-faire
et la main-d'oeuvre qui
est indispensable à l'économie nationale.
Les coutumes sont celles
d'un pays où l'islam est pratiqué
par la quasi-totalité de la population.
Le Qatar est un pays islamique modéré.
Convictions religieuses
sont adaptés au monde actuel.
Intégrer le logement à l'environnement
révèle le même sens de l'adaptation.
Pendant des siècles, les tribus nomades
appris à vivre dans un environnement hostile.
Une fois installés,
les nomades toujours basés
leur idée de maison sur la tente.
A l'abri du vent, du sable et du soleil,
il n'y avait pas de meilleure protection.
Lignes légères et fluides contrastées
avec les formes de l'architecture
importé par les civilisations occidentales
au début du XVIe siècle.
Le pays s'est enflammé
intérêt commercial étranger considérable
au milieu du 20ème siècle.
La richesse tirée de la pêche aux perles
n'était pas tout ce que les gens avaient en vue.
Une nouvelle perle avait surgi du sol,
représentant un véritable trésor,
le troisième plus grand
réserve de gaz naturel dans le monde.
Le gaz et le pétrole
fournissent 85% des revenus d'exportation.
Ils fournissent également
le pouvoir de produire de l'électricité.
Le développement dépend
sur les lignes électriques qui transportent l'électricité.
Comme par magie,
le désert s'est transformé.
Il n'est pas toujours facile de distinguer
entre mirage et réalité.
Le chameau, le bateau
du désert s'est adapté à la vie citadine,
tandis que les automobiles traversent le désert.
Les sites industriels se multiplient,
nécessitant toujours plus d'infrastructures.
La technologie et le génie
du génie civil a donné le ton.
Le Qatar voyage
à travers le temps à grands pas.
Plus de 1 000 ans d'histoire sont derrière
sa grande marche vers l'avenir.
La croissance économique est stable
dans un pays qui compte environ
un million d'habitants,
mais la perle du passé
n'a pas été oublié.
La coquille et sa forme gracieuse
influence les urbanistes et les architectes
dans la conception du bâtiment
complexes de demain.
Ils travaillent
sans relâche pour préparer l'avenir
qui pointe à l'horizon.
L'objectif est très ambitieux,
mais le Qatar a préparé
le sol pour son décollage.
Au bord du désert,
un pays crée de nouvelles formes,
celles qui façonneront l'avenir.
Récupéré du désert,
Doha a été fondée au milieu des années 1800
quand il est devenu un protectorat britannique.
Le long du front de mer,
la Corniche s'étend sur sept kilomètres
vers les formes futuristes
du quartier West Bay.
Doha était à l'origine
un petit village de pêcheurs, mais le temps passe vite.
La Corniche de Doha
est un lieu de rencontre pour les poussettes.
Le vendredi, les boutres,
les bateaux traditionnels,
débarquer des familles entières.
Ils viennent ici pique-niquer sur l'herbe
au pied des immeubles modernes.
Bien qu'aucun vêtement
des restrictions sont imposées aux femmes,
la plupart portent la longue abaya noire.
Au bord de West Bay,
les premiers architectes avaient déjà prouvé
leur sens de l'originalité.
Aujourd'hui, une véritable forêt
de gratte-ciel a vu le jour.
Il y avait, en effet,
pas vraiment besoin de construire des gratte-ciel
à cause de tout l'espace disponible.
Les bâtiments sont en eux-mêmes,
le signe extérieur du succès,
et Doha a beaucoup
attentes pour l'avenir.
Une architecture sans contraintes
a conduit à la fusion
entre tradition et modernité.
Ibrahim Jeddah, architecte.
Le ciel est vraiment ta limite
ici au Qatar en tant qu'architecte.
Beaucoup d'endroits
en Europe et en Occident,
sont très limités
aux bâtiments environnants.
Ici le ciel est ta limite
en termes de style, de hauteur, de fonction,
et il y a généralement
des idées audacieuses ici au Qatar.
Pourquoi ne pas avoir des gondoliers vénitiens
ramer au pied des immeubles ?
Oui, il faut souvent oser
parce que l'ambition est grande
et rien n'est impossible.
Ce n'est sûrement pas si simple.
Le problème majeur est l'échelle,
nous ne sommes pas vraiment habitués.
Il y a seulement cinq, six ans,
Le Qatar a commencé à monter haut.
Habituellement, nous allons horizontalement.
Le défi ici est d'aller très haut,
tout en conservant une saveur d'où il appartient.
Nous avons tendance à perdre cette identité
lorsqu'il devient extrêmement élevé.
Partout, des lignes orientales
rivaliser d'élégance avec les courbes western.
L'économie florissante
de l'État du Qatar
repose sur un sol solide.
Le gouvernement a choisi
diversifier ses ressources
en tournant la capitale
dans un important centre financier.
Par exemple, la rue Hamar al Kabir
C'est là que se trouvent toutes les banques,
où tout
a tendance à prendre la couleur de l'or,
même les perles.
Ici personne n'oublie
que tout a commencé avec les perles
qui ont été pêchés dans les profondeurs de l'eau
au prix d'efforts considérables.
Il est également impossible
ignorer l'influence islamique.
C'est l'axe autour duquel s'enroule le Qatar.
La spirale du minaret
suit le chemin d'un monde en mouvement.
Toutes les composantes de la société traditionnelle
restent toujours présents, mais sont mis à jour.
L'architecture du Musée
des arts islamiques en est un bon exemple.
Son jeu subtil sur les cubes a été conçu
par le créateur de la pyramide du Louvre.
L'architecte américain Liu Ming Pei.
Madame Sabiha Alchemiya
est conservateur du musée.
Lorsqu'on lui a demandé de concevoir
le Musée d'art islamique de Doha,
I.M. Pei s'est lancé dans un long voyage
dans tout le monde islamique.
Il cherchait
pour l'essence de l'architecture islamique,
et ce voyage
est passé de l'Afrique du Nord à l'Irak en passant par l'Egypte,
partout au Moyen-Orient.
Ce que Pei a fait
prend l'architecture islamique,
la racine de la tradition, à la modernité.
Les objets exposés
viennent ici de trois continents.
Ils couvrent 13 siècles
d'une brillante civilisation.
Ils vont de la poterie,
verre, ferronnerie, tapis,
essentiellement de la faïence à la soie,
et de Cordoue en Espagne
à Samarcande en Asie centrale.
C'est une vaste zone géographique,
et est du VIIe siècle
quand l'Islam est venu à ce jour.
Très proche du musée
et à l'ombre des gratte-ciel
est un chantier hors du temps,
où sont construits les boutres
selon les techniques anciennes.
Le boutre est un
bateau d'occasion dans l'Océan Indien,
et particulièrement le long des côtes du Golfe.
Ils sont généralement construits en teck,
un bois qui ne pourrit pas.
La coque est assemblée à l'aide de piquets en bois
et la poupe a une forme carrée.
Une des propriétés du teck
est de durcir après qu'il est mouillé.
La proue du boutre
a laissé son empreinte dans le ciel.
Autre tradition, le souk,
un mot qui en arabe
signifie marché de la vieille ville.
L'ancien souk de Doha a été restauré
et a maintenu toutes ses activités,
qui sont divisés en différentes sections.
Instruments de musique traditionnels.
Préparation du pain traditionnel.
Tout ici reflète
un aspect du passé.
A l'intérieur du souk,
bijoux, gemmes et métaux précieux
ont été confectionnés
par les bijoutiers qatariens depuis des générations.
Au début, les artisans
avait du matériel de choix disponible ici,
qui était très prisé
monde entier, des perles naturelles.
Aujourd'hui, les perles sont importées.
C'est le petit-fils d'un pêcheur de perles.
Il est vendeur de perles et aussi
un artiste qui crée des images magnifiques
en utilisant des bois de différentes nuances.
Ses œuvres rappellent parfois
l'artisanat complexe de ses ancêtres.
Avec un extraordinaire
sens du détail, il utilise de vraies perles
pour un effet de mise en valeur spécial,
un travail d'une grande finesse.
Il y a deux choses
réunis dans cet art du travail du bois,
l'art de la sculpture,
comme dans la création de l'image de l'émir,
et aussi l'art
d'assembler les multiples nuances de bois.
Il y a un nombre incroyable
de morceaux de bois dans ces portraits.
Une image en trois dimensions
plus expressif qu'une photographie.
Au souk des fruits et légumes,
c'est surprenant de voir
une telle variété de produits et de couleurs,
surtout compte tenu du nombre limité
possibilité d'agriculture au Qatar.
C'est pourquoi la plupart des produits
en magasin arrive du monde entier.
Produits volumineux
et déménagement de marchandises
sont vendus dans un autre souk.
Le rude climat désertique
et l'absence de pâturages
sont des obstacles à l'élevage.
Les souks traditionnels coexistent
avec des souks plus contemporains.
Formes modernes, formes exotiques,
plus c'est gigantesque, mieux c'est.
A l'intérieur, l'air est toujours frais
et le vent
ne chassera jamais les nuages.
Les centres commerciaux
sont d'énormes bulles climatisées.
Des bulles qui fonctionnent indépendamment
quelle que soit leur situation géographique.
Quelle que soit la température extérieure,
la patinoire fait toujours tourner la tête.
Rien ne peut refroidir l'attraction
que les Qataris ont pour les biens de consommation.
Autre plaisir qatari, le parfum.
Le mot parfum signifiait à l'origine
substances aromatiques brûlées.
Le parfum a existé dans le
Moyen-Orient depuis l'Antiquité.
La tradition est importante au Qatar.
Néanmoins, le pays
ne s'est pas coupé du présent.
Il est résolument tourné
vers l'extérieur vers l'avenir.
Conformément à cet objectif est Al Jazeera,
la chaîne de télévision par satellite
créé par l'émir en 1996.
C'est devenu un
des principales chaînes d'information dans le monde,
tout en présentant l'actualité
du point de vue arabe.
La gare a construit
un mémorial aux journalistes
qui ont été tués au travail.
Le mur de la liberté est un rappel
de leur dévouement à la profession
et des risques encourus.
Un musée a été créé
avec un certain nombre d'objets personnels
qui appartiennent aux journalistes
employé par la chaîne
et qui est mort en couvrant l'actualité.
Pour préparer l'avenir,
Le Qatar a créé la Qatar Foundation,
présidé par Son Altesse Royale,
la femme de l'émir.
Des fonds considérables ont été
investis pour aider tout le peuple qatari
relever les défis qui les attendent.
En respectant les lignes
de l'architecture traditionnelle,
mais aussi en faisant appel
les maîtres de l'architecture contemporaine,
un immense complexe
a été construit, Education City.
Une idée simple, mais audacieuse
fonder un campus
pas en créant une université,
mais en regroupant plusieurs des meilleurs
campus dans le monde sur un même site.
L'ampleur astronomique des investissements,
les techniques de pointe
et les meilleurs professeurs
recrutés dans le monde entier
ont rapidement donné
renommée internationale à cette réalisation.
Les couleurs vives sont particulièrement bonnes
pour capter l'attention des enfants,
pour leur avoir ouvert les yeux sur le monde,
et les aider à mieux le comprendre.
Un esprit ouvert
et la tolérance sont les objectifs
qui a motivé la création
de la chaîne pour enfants Al Jazeera.
La chaîne vise l'éducation
et le divertissement des enfants arabes.
Il dispose de toutes les installations pour produire de nombreux
des programmes éducatifs qui sont aussi amusants.
La taille des projets
qui ont été dotés
par la Fondation du Qatar est conforme
à la mesure de ses ambitions.
Le nouveau Palais des Congrès
sera le plus grand
dans tout le Moyen-Orient.
Les palmiers se demandent
où leur désert est allé.
Le Qatar a créé des plans monumentaux
pour le stade Al Khalifa.
À la pointe de la technologie
conception d'architecture sportive,
une tour de 320 mètres de haut en forme
d'une flamme domine la ville des sports.
La qualité de ses installations sportives
est un immense atout pour le Qatar,
qui a organisé les Jeux Asiatiques en 2006.
Le pays est maintenant
dans l'attente des Jeux olympiques.
En déclarant son ardent désir
pour les Jeux olympiques,
Le Qatar profite évidemment
d'un atout majeur dans son infrastructure.
Le Qatar dispose également d'un
ressource éducative appelée Aspire.
Entraîner les jeunes futurs champions sous
son aile est la vocation de cette institution.
Elle soutient ainsi l'ambition
de se faire un nom
au niveau de la compétition internationale.
Dieta Hackford est directrice d'Aspire.
Aspire, l'Académie
for Sports Excellence est une académie unique
avec les installations les plus avancées,
Je peux dire, dans le monde.
Non seulement les installations sont les plus avancées,
mais aussi les programmes d'éducation
et la valorisation des sports d'élite
et l'entraînement des jeunes athlètes.
L'idée de base est de créer des champions
dans le pays et d'autre part,
pour imposer une culture sportive ici au Qatar.
Élever des athlètes qatariens
au niveau international
vaut bien le prix.
Les jeunes candidats sont pris en main.
Ils partagent une vie commune
dans quels cours scolaires
font partie d'un programme très intensif.
Ici, le sport contribue
pour créer de nouvelles formes,
les formes du futur.
Organisation d'événements sportifs de haut niveau
a rendu le Qatar célèbre dans le monde entier.
Il fallait d'abord conquérir le désert.
Le club de golf de Doha
organise le Qatar Masters.
L'exploit est remarquable
puisque le parcours 18 trous appelle les canards
au milieu du désert
et parmi les cactus.
L'herbe ici est un tel luxe.
On pourrait penser que les balles de golf sont des perles.
Les chevaux ont toujours accompagné
les populations nomades du Moyen-Orient.
Ils ont appartenu
à la culture arabe pendant des siècles.
Pour l'élevage et l'entraînement des chevaux,
Le Qatar est devenu une place de choix.
Les chevaux sont un
des grandes passions de l'Emir.
Ses fermes équestres
sont célèbres dans le monde entier,
et ses chevaux ont remporté de nombreux prix.
Les Qataris sont devenus de grands fans de courses.
La longue présence britannique
dans le pays peut expliquer en grande partie
pourquoi les Qataris sont
tellement intéressé par les courses de chevaux.
Au Qatar, un autre animal qui
les Qataris sont dévoués au Faucon.
Cet oiseau de proie appartient
à une tradition séculaire
qui fait oiseau
et maîtres partenaires de chasse.
Les Falcons ont leurs propres hôpitaux.
L'oiseau est souvent blessé
parce qu'il chasse
en percutant sa proie à grande vitesse.
Les fractures sont fréquentes.
Pendant la chirurgie,
l'oiseau est sous anesthésie.
Une petite lacération ici.
Ceci est causé pendant la formation
quand il atterrit
ou attaquer un pigeon
ou un oiseau dans le désert,
il a heurté une pierre.
Le propriétaire est très inquiet
pendant qu'il assiste à l'opération.
Le faucon dressé est d'une grande valeur,
à la fois sentimental et financier.
Un autre type d'opération
remplacement d'une plume.
La plume endommagée est épissée.
Chaque plume est référencée
selon la taille et le positionnement.
L'étrave est simplement glissée dans l'aile.
Aucune autre fixation n'est nécessaire.
Le Faucon se réveille
et est prêt à reprendre le travail.
Nous sommes tous prêts pour une chasse
expédition dans le désert.
La proie est libérée.
Le faucon s'envole.
Le fauconnier garde l'oiseau en vue.
L'oiseau fond sur sa proie,
qui n'a aucune chance.
Le faucon est le plus rapide
animal dans toute la création.
C'est au tour d'un autre Falcon.
Il disparaît de la vue.
Heureusement, le fauconnier
a un gadget fidèle dans son quatre par quatre.
Il a localisé le faucon.
La proie s'était réfugiée dans un buisson,
mais est évincé de sa cachette
et est immédiatement rattrapé.
Les chasseurs récompensent,
permission de dévorer sa victime.
N'aurait-il pas pu l'attraper plus tôt ?
C'est à cause du vent.
C'est pourquoi il a fallu beaucoup de temps pour attraper,
sinon, il devrait l'attraper rapidement.
Le faucon a été localisé,
grâce à une antenne et un émetteur.
Cap vers l'ouest à travers le désert.
On voit des silhouettes familières,
un autre animal
qui est traditionnellement présent.
A l'horizon, un camp de tentes
a été aménagé dans le style bédouin.
Les Qataris sont très attachés à leur
coutumes ancestrales et mode de vie
sans renoncer
les avantages du monde moderne.
Au camping, la coutume
la division du travail est respectée.
Ce sont les femmes qui font
les ornements portés par les chameaux.
Ils préparent aussi des beignets
et autres plats traditionnels.
Tout le monde est ici en l'honneur de l'animal
qui fait leur existence
dans le désert possible, le chameau.
Pour le chameau,
la journée commence par une bonne douche.
Beaucoup de gens aiment les chameaux.
Pour moi, c'est mon passe-temps.
Les courses de chameaux sont extrêmement populaires ici.
J'ai toujours mon âme bédouine vous savez.
Les Qataris sont des fans passionnés
de cet événement, les courses de chameaux.
On commence par un petit échauffement.
Une étrange silhouette
est apparu sur le circuit.
C'est un robot,
et c'est habillé comme un jockey.
Le fouet est actionné
par signaux vocaux de la télécommande
ou par une pression sur un porte-clés.
Les chameaux étaient autrefois montés par des enfants.
Les Qataris ont été les premiers
adopter l'utilisation de jockeys robotisés.
Depuis,
tous les jockeys pèsent exactement le même poids.
Alors que l'heure du départ approche,
les chameaux doivent s'aligner
dans le sens de la course.
Il n'y a pas d'exceptions à cette règle.
Tout est bientôt pris en charge.
Prêts partez.
Les caméras sont éteintes,
accompagné d'un groupe de voitures.
La piste est bordée de deux voies
utilisé par les propriétaires de chameaux
rouler le long de la course,
piloter leurs SUV
ainsi que leurs cavaliers.
Toujours dans leur enclos,
les femelles semblent extrêmement nerveuses.
Ils se sont fait coiffer.
Ils portent leur plus belle tenue.
Que se passe-t-il?
Un jury d'experts consiste à
pour juger laquelle est la plus belle.
Aspect général et nombreux
d'autres détails sont rigoureusement enregistrés.
Dans un concours de beauté,
tout doit être officiel.
Et le gagnant est...
Une nouvelle étoile est née et le concours
se termine par des danses et des chants.
Plus à l'ouest sur le site de Zikreet,
le vent sablonneux sculpte les roches calcaires
selon son caprice.
Dans le jeu des ombres,
les formes changent constamment.
Ici aussi,
il n'y a pas de limite à la créativité.
La côte ouest du Qatar
se trouve sur le golfe de Bahreïn.
Les grandes plages pourraient certainement
accueillir de nombreux baigneurs,
mais activité ici
se limite à l'exploitation du pétrole.
Les principaux champs pétrolifères du pays
sont en fait situés sur la côte ouest.
Les pipelines serpentent
dans toute cette région.
Le pétrole a été découvert ici
par les Britanniques à la fin des années 1930.
Le Qatar entrait dans une nouvelle ère.
Quittant la capitale et se dirigeant vers le nord,
le désert reprend rapidement ses droits.
Plus on avance,
plus le paysage devient stérile.
Le désert, cependant,
n'est pas qu'une vaste étendue de terre
où la vie est insoutenable.
Surprise, nous trouvons des cultures qui poussent
sur des parcelles soigneusement délimitées.
Une autre surprise,
il y a une grande variété de cultures,
mais la végétation
ne pourrait pas survivre
sans l'aide d'un système d'irrigation.
Ils peuvent même faire pousser des tomates,
grâce à une gestion rigoureuse de l'irrigation.
Avec certains légumes,
approvisionnements de la production locale
70% de la consommation du Qatar.
Incroyables vaches laitières
sont élevés dans le désert,
animaux peu résistants à la chaleur.
Pourtant ça marche,
spécialement là où la technologie est nécessaire.
Lorsque la chaleur excessive
présente un risque pour les vaches,
les humidificateurs sont mis
en action et les stores sont baissés.
Le processus de traite
se déroule dans un environnement stérile,
et fabrication
est contrôlé par ordinateur à chaque étape.
Hussein Salem.
La traite est gérée par ordinateur,
qui optimise la quantité
et la qualité du lait.
La technologie permet également de rationaliser
de toutes les procédures de travail agricole.
Certains travaux manuels subsistent,
mais c'est l'ordinateur qui détermine
la quantité de lait à collecter.
Nous trayons les vaches deux ou trois fois par jour.
Chaque vache a un numéro
et porte un transpondeur,
qui est relié à un ordinateur
qui traite
toutes les données sur l'animal.
Un autre animal élevé ici, l'oryx.
Cet animal, emblématique du Qatar,
prospérait autrefois à l'état sauvage dans cette région,
mais est venu très près de l'extinction.
Les gazelles font également partie de la faune locale.
Ils ont presque été anéantis par les chasseurs,
mais aujourd'hui, ils prospèrent dans les fermes d'élevage.
Ils sont très appréciés
pour leur viande et leur peau.
Les îles au large
sont une halte pour les oiseaux migrateurs.
Bordure de mangroves denses
sur le désert à certains endroits.
Plus au nord,
la route du désert se rapproche de la mer.
Les villes font face au Golfe
et leur survie en dépend.
Les boutres ne sont pas utilisés
comme bateaux de plaisance, mais comme bateaux de pêche.
Le port d'Al-Ruwais
est à l'extrémité nord de la péninsule.
La pêche en est une
des activités traditionnelles du Qatar.
Aujourd'hui, ceux qui gagnent leur vie
car les pêcheurs sont des travailleurs immigrés.
Le fort d'Al Zubarah a été construit
en 1938 pour se prémunir contre les dangers
qui venait de la mer.
À l'époque, le Qatar répondait
aux fortifications construites à Bahreïn.
La région était déjà une plaque tournante
d'un trafic commercial intense.
Munir Tahar est archéologue.
Au cours des 18e et 19e siècles,
Zubarah était un centre commercial
pour l'ensemble de la zone du golfe Persique.
C'était connecté
à Bassorah du nord,
Oman du sud
et de là à l'Afrique de l'Est à l'ouest
et à l'est
de la vallée de l'Indus jusqu'à la Chine.
Exposée à l'intérieur du fort
sont des objets trouvés dans la région
lors des fouilles archéologiques des ruines.
La ville était autrefois
un centre commercial prospère.
Il y a un port important à Zubarah,
également mentionné dans les livres historiques.
Et Zubarah
était également célèbre dans l'industrie perlière.
Les perles étaient exportées
à de nombreux pays.
Zubarah était un port international,
que vous pouvez utiliser n'importe quelle sorte de devise.
La ville de Zubarah,
protégé par ses remparts
dès le XVIIIe siècle,
était idéalement situé.
L'importance de ce site prouve que
l'ouverture du pays vers l'extérieur
n'est pas seulement l'histoire récente.
Voyager vers le sud, Arabie Saoudite
n'est qu'à 75 kilomètres.
Quittant immédiatement la capitale derrière nous
est une région au sud
où règne la loi du désert.
Il n'y aura pas d'obstacles
sur la route autre que d'immenses dunes de sable.
Seule la côte de la mer
met fin au désert.
Soudain, derrière une montagne de sable
s'élève l'un des emblèmes
de l'économie qatarienne,
l'énorme
complexe industriel de Mesaieed.
Le gaz naturel, qui constitue
principale richesse du pays,
est traité ici.
L'un des plus grands gisements de gaz au monde
a été découvert au Qatar dans les années 1970.
Les installations de Mesaieed sont équipées
avec une technologie de traitement sophistiquée.
Celles-ci impliquent un refroidissement
le gaz naturel pour le liquéfier
puis assurer son transport
dans ce volume inférieur, forme plus stable.
Une véritable ville industrielle
a été créé à partir de rien,
et les installations de Mesaieed
sont constamment
en cours d'amélioration et d'extension.
Si la consommation mondiale de gaz naturel
est maintenu à son niveau actuel
et si le Qatar continue
maintenir son rythme d'exportation,
il est estimé
que l'exploitation des réserves de gaz
pourrait durer plus de 200 ans.
C'est là que commence l'avenir du pays.
Pour se diriger vers le sud,
nous suivons simplement le littoral.
Une oasis inattendue
apparaît entre désert et mer.
Une oasis de confort et de tranquillité.
Soudain, des cavaliers bédouins
apparaissent en grande tenue.
Les couleurs nationales flottent fièrement.
Déjeuner inattendu sur l'herbe
et jeunes sportifs
qui nous fait part de ce qui se passe.
Bien sûr, des vélos.
En janvier, la tournée du Qatar
commence la saison cycliste
Sous la direction
de l'ex-champion Eddy Merckx.
Je pense que c'est un moyen idéal
pour se réchauffer pour la saison.
Les étapes ne sont pas trop longues.
Les cyclistes reviennent
au même hôtel tous les soirs,
c'est donc le moyen idéal
pour se mettre en condition.
C'est le seul endroit du pays
où le paysage semble onduler.
C'est à cause des Barkhans,
les dunes de sable en forme de croissant.
Traces, silhouettes,
formes,
le duning de sable en 4x4 est devenu
passe-temps favori des Qataris.
Le terrain de sport s'éternise.
Ce qui est vraiment intéressant, c'est de trouver des dunes
personne n'a jamais conduit avant.
Trouver de nouveaux terrains.
C'est un vrai hobby, tu sais.
Le terrain est constamment renouvelé
parce que le vent
efface régulièrement les traces de pneus
et le désert
se prête à tous types de véhicules.
Tout cela ressemble à un safari.
Nous campons quelque part.
Nous venons d'arriver ici.
La côte sud nous amène à un canal
qui débouche sur une petite mer intérieure.
De l'autre côté, l'Arabie Saoudite.
Les tentes ressemblent à de la ponctuation
marques dans l'immensité.
Pendant plusieurs heures ou plusieurs jours,
Les Qataris viennent communier avec le désert.
C'est une façon de retourner à leurs origines,
ce qui ne veut pas dire
laissant derrière nous le monde moderne.
Cette chambre n'est pas dans une tente en toile
et la climatisation vous rend
oublie vite la température extérieure.
Il va bientôt faire nuit.
Pour les goutteurs de jour,
il est temps de retourner dans cet autre monde.
La réalité tourne
dans un mirage extraordinaire,
et incroyable gymkhana.
La lune illumine Doha,
illuminant des rangées de perles.
Le désert a reculé,
mais les frontières,
à la fois moderne et traditionnel,
Sont toujours là.
La maison s'est illuminée
comme une tente pour la fête.
Coutumes ancestrales en cours
au pied des gratte-ciel.
La mosquée est un point de repère dans la nuit.
C'est une fête de mariage.
Les invités présentent leurs compliments.
Les hommes se rassemblent dans une zone,
les femmes dans un autre.
Les cafetières sont chauffées
tout comme ils sont dans le dessert.
L'encens est encore utilisé
en signe de bienvenue.
Avec des dates.
Au coeur même de la ville moderne,
la tradition va
main dans la main avec le présent.
Perles de lumière
faire revivre les danses traditionnelles,
une danse bédouine
réservé aux occasions très spéciales.
La danse de l'épée.
Après les danses, la fête.
Le plat traditionnel d'agneau
avec du riz appelé Majboos.
Tu manges avec la main droite
et avec la main droite uniquement.
Demain, une nouvelle vie
commence pour l'époux.
A l'ombre ou à la lumière,
Le Qatar est dans le processus
de relever le défi.
Concilier identité et modernité.
Comme dans un rêve éveillé,
le pays émerge tout droit
du désert, de la tente au gratte-ciel,
avec presque aucune transition entre les deux.
Il est entré dans une nouvelle ère.
Tu dois te frotter les yeux
croire ce que vous voyez.
Aux poètes arabes des siècles passés,
les perles étaient des larmes de lune.
Les perles d'aujourd'hui
ont apporté des changements écrasants
à la vie des Qataris,
mais pas à leurs valeurs essentielles.
Ils sont devenus les perles du futur.